on the next episode of AMC's The Walking
Dead Maggie said that her people could
take care of the Savior's so far all
they've done let's put our community at
risk we need to talk I'm not seeing you
anymore
it's our way out
why don't you go with my dad I have to
figure some things out what is it figure
out how we can do this yeah we can't no
no like this your dad thinks differently
and he's wrong you know it even if I
think he is I don't know
change your baggage later really nice to
Olivia hey youtubers is Charlie so new
Walking Dead let's break it down Trevor
from Grand Theft Auto is totally back so
as you can see Maggie doing just fine
with the doctor at Hilltop next week
Berryhill top heavy episode so we'll
pick back up with Jesus
Gregory their leader who is a nice
juxtaposition from Ezekiel like you can
see the Trevor and the Savior's roll up
and are like look we're changing the
deal you guys are all screwed now and
Gregory's just totally ready to roll
over
remember the hilltop community is
relatively small compared to the safe
zone compared to the kingdom so Gregory
unlike Ezekiel or even Rick even Rick
after negan is a stronger personality
think Gregory is just ready to
completely do whatever negan and the
Savior's want or really Trevor from
Grand Theft Auto because that's who he's
dealing with here but a lot of what
they're doing with their setting up here
is all comic book stuff from march to
war so without giving away spoilers like
they're just trying to tell you Gregory
is probably going to be a problem so the
title of the episode the next deal means
a couple different things like you have
the Savior's here trying to push their
new deal on hilltop then in that clip
with Michonne and Carl they talk about
Rick's new deal so they'll probably
follow up with Maggie I'm not expecting
to see too much kingdom stuff in the
episode I think mostly what they're
trying to imply is that the survivors
are gonna try and work something out
with hilltop but at the same time the
Savior's will also try to do that and
douchebag Gregory will somehow get in
the way of all this and it'll be funny
to see if Gregory tries to perv out with
Maggie again
the last time she was that he was kind
of creepin on her but that's also from
the comics too like Gregory takes this
weird fascination with Maggie while
she's getting her exam done but given
was just happened to Maggie we'll see
how they treat her character in this
episode because one she was basically on
the edge of death then she also went
through the trauma of losing Glenn
Abraham and what happened with the
survivors so the main concern was in her
losing the baby but you can kind of see
what they're doing with her character
like this is gonna be her whole to climb
out of like they wouldn't save her then
just to have negan turn around and kill
her or kill her baby it's gonna be like
this
big story of triumph at least that seems
like the direction they're taking things
we also see Sasha sharpening her knife
at Hilltop she looks like she's ready
for business so it really does see like
we're in the middle of volume 19 march
to war so if you want to read along in
the comics just read volume 19 march to
war it makes sense that this is building
towards volume 20 all-out war which
would be like a really big action set
piece way to end a season or begin a
season but we'll just see how close to
the comics they stake and how fast they
speed along but you guys can let me know
do you think that they'll blow through
march to war the first half of the
season or do you think that'll spill
into the second half of the season I
think they've been a little bit clearer
with the way they've treated Maggie's
character in the arc that they're
setting up for her then with Rick's
character like he hasn't been on quite
as big a journey like you have that
episode one moment where he breaks but
in this past episode episode 4 he didn't
seem like quite as much of a coward as
expected but he looked like at any
moment he might lash out at negan so you
can see that eventually we'll just get
to some moment where he can't stand it
anymore and he will want to go against
negan but the whole idea with that
episode one moment where he's like
groveling on the ground just like
completely broken down
is that negan really did break him Rick
is not acting and something has to shake
him out of his funk and it didn't seem
like there was any clear moment where
that happened during episode 4 so
there's still a couple more episodes
before the mid-season finale
maybe we'll see that happen sometime
during that but you have to remember
that they do not have any guns like even
went as far as to ask Michonne if she is
also secretly hiding more weapons
somewhere so that he can get rid of them
so there is a huge corner to be turned
before he starts plotting against the
Savior's but the funny thing is that it
seems like everybody else is kind of
doing it for him so when he finally gets
to that moment where he says enough is
enough everybody else will already be
prepared but give away time I'll say it
congratulations to this week's Walking
Dead giveaway winner chase Morgan you
win a $20 Amazon gift card please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details and later today I will be
posting a Westworld video
just explaining all the theories kind of
catching people up on the series they
were confirmed for season two like they
already got their pickup so there will
be a 10 episode season - I'm assuming
it'll air around the same time next year
as season 1 started like around this
time so I'll post that video in a couple
hours be sure to subscribe to get that
it's actually been a lot of fun but like
Walking Dead it also has to pay off some
of the big things that it sets up and it
hasn't done that quite yet while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for last night's episode of The
Walking Dead and you can click here for
my Game of Thrones Theory video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight